[Música]
y
algunos ha tenido ganas de ayudar pero
le ha dado miedo que la ayuda no llegue
donde debe llegar a mí me ha pasado y
creo que a muchos de nosotros nos pasa y
por eso miren este contexto marzo 2020
empieza la pandemia empieza la primera
semana de cuarentena pero sabíamos que
esto iba a ser largo y profundo
empezamos un grupo de colegas que a lo
largo de la vida
habíamos como decimos nosotros luchado
mil batallas en los temas sociales
empezamos a conversar y a decir cómo
hacemos para asegurar que las ayudas se
canalizan y llegan a donde deben llegar
de esa forma nace un gran colectivo que
empieza con esa preocupación se crea un
grupo de whatsapp y empiezan a sumarse y
a sumarse y a sumarse aliados que hoy en
día somos más de 400
y eso lo logramos porque nos une esa
misma preocupación y un propósito que es
ayudar ese propósito de ayudar merece la
pena
poder trabajar juntos construir juntos y
trabajar en colectivo porque cuando
trabajamos en colectivo
logramos mover montañas logramos
solucionar problemas que a lo largo de
la vida nos han aquejado y que pensamos
que no tienen solución pero cuando
logras juntar la persona que tiene la
fundación que logra entregar alimentos a
las poblaciones más necesitadas en los
momentos de crisis y juntas además a la
empresa que dona los alimentos o que
dona los recursos para entregar esa
ayuda y además juntas a ese líder
comunitario que te sabe de verdad
indicar dónde se necesitan las ayudas y
a esto además le sumamos tecnología
bases de datos cruce de información con
las entregas de ayudas que están
haciendo el gobierno otras fundaciones
pues lo que logras es una gran fórmula
y desarrollo se logra una gran solución
para la gente que más lo necesita en los
momentos de crisis
en esos momentos históricamente habíamos
realmente visto que las ayudas a veces
las venden en una tienda o las personas
terminan comprando una casa nueva y que
supuestamente estaban ayudando pero
están comprando una casa nueva y uno
dice pero por qué pues porque realmente
la estructura como estaba diseñada antes
de trabajar en colectivo era una
estructura de islas donde intermediar de
forma no tan clara las ayudas era fácil
pero cuando ya estás integrando al
donante con el ejecutor con el
beneficiario en una misma conversación y
literal en un grupo de whatsapp
en ese momento neutraliza cualquier
posibilidad de corrupción y además si no
fuese corrupción sino que es
ineficiencia logras también articular
desde la demanda hasta la oferta toda la
línea y de esa forma se logra hacer
mucho más eficiente en la entrega de
ayudas
por eso es muy importante que ese
propósito común que es ayudar y esa
preocupación inicial que es cómo logró
que esa ayuda llegue donde más se
necesite se articule desde esa
construcción conjunta y eso se logra con
unos pasos muy sencillos
el primero es convocar a quienes tienen
las soluciones oa quienes pueden
conectar oferta con demanda lo segundo
es preguntarle a todos los que uno
conecta de entrada que puedes dar y qué
quieres recibir de esta alianza porque
muchas veces en el sector social nos
sentamos a contarnos lo buenos que somos
pero no avanzamos y no avanzamos es
porque no nos hacemos esa primera
pregunta que espero y que quiero de ahí
en adelante tenemos que continuar
haciendo las preguntas ideales para
construir una solución entonces si veo
que hay un problema de inundación me
pregunto quién es el experto en manejar
inundación
como lo traigo hasta esta zona que
aliado necesito necesito un avión como
consigo a la empresa del avión y así
haciendo las preguntas se va
construyendo la solución en un método
que es ágil muy flexible y sobre todo
rápido porque realmente la rapidez de
las soluciones es muy importante de esa
forma llegamos antes que aquellos
intermediarios que están buscando su
beneficio propio y no el beneficio común
y por eso el cuarto paso ahí es medir
los resultados es muy importante que
midamos los resultados y esa pregunta la
tenemos que tener desde el principio
desde la primera reunión que esperamos
alcanzar nosotros por ejemplo alcanzamos
dos millones de personas impactadas en
siete meses de pandemia y en este
momento que estamos viviendo la ola
invernal estamos con capacidad de
atender a los cientos de miles de
colombianos que están sufriendo con esta
crisis invernal
entonces si ven
la articulación de todos desde construir
ganar-ganar desde construir tú qué
esperas yo que espero logra que las
soluciones se articulen de una manera
sólida y que sigamos construyendo
independiente del problema
la estructura funciona bien para la
solución y por eso todos los que quieren
cumplir un propósito que ven un problema
que quieren solucionar pueden hacerlo
pueden hacerlo trabajando con este
método de convocar preguntar hacer
seguimiento a los resultados y luego
volver a empezar y tirar y volver a
empezar desde el principio qué esperas
tú qué es pero yo por eso todo el mundo
lo puede hacer así que es solo que
empiecen
[Música]